good evening everyone
my name is madeline schmidt i am a
junior
rhetoric major at hillsdale college and
it is my absolute pleasure to introduce
mr roger kimball this evening
roger kimball is editor and publisher
of the new criterion and president and
publisher of
encounter books a contributor
to numerous publications including
the epic times the sunday telegraph
the american spectator and american
greatness
mr kimball is editor co-editor
or author of numerous books including
ethwort history half a century of
polemics animated versions and
illuminations
a william f buckley junior omnibus
the long march how the cultural
revolution of the 1960s
changed america vox populi the perils
and promises
of populism and most recently
who rules sovereignty nationalism
and the fate of freedom in the 21st
century
will everyone please welcome me in
joining
mr roger kimball
[Applause]
thank you maddie i thought you're going
to say something about my fabulous bow
tie
well it's a pleasure to be back at
hillsdale
a little oasis of sanity
well since this conference is about the
liberal arts and education today
and my own slice of that pie concerns
freedom
and education i'd like to begin with a
question
and it's one that i'd like you to keep
in mind as the evening
unfolds the question is this
what is liberal about a liberal
education
now that question is not as easy to
answer
as you might think for one thing really
to answer it
you have to know what the word liberal
means can you think of
any word that has accumulated more
conflicting meanings than the word
liberal
and then there's a word education who
wants to give that one a try
in my experience the more you think
about those simple words
the more elusive are their meanings
in the materials distributed for this
conference there is a cheery quotation
from james
madison co-author of the federalist
papers and a principal author of the u s
constitution says that liberty
and learning belong together they
support
each other he says and further
their connection supports a free society
in various forms the nexus between
liberty and
learning is a very traditional idea
one that has epistemological and
existential
as well as political dimensions
aristotle begins the book we call
metaphysics
with the observation that all men
by nature desire to know
aristotle thought that learning freed us
gave us liberty from the snares of
ignorance
illusion and mere appearance
learning he thought not only depends
upon
but also begets certain freedoms
in the gospel according to saint john
jesus says that you shall know the truth
and the truth
shall set you free
in the gospel the relevant freedom is
freedom from sin
but that point can be generalized which
is why
various schools and colleges have
adopted the saying
as their motto and it's perhaps
worth noting that the cia
liked the quotation so much that they
had it etched into a wall
of their headquarters it's amusing to
speculate what the author of that saying
would make of this spooky application of
his words
the greek word that the evangelist john
uses for truth
is aletheia alathia interestingly
it has a negative form ah lathe
etymologically it means not forgetful
in greek mythology the river leafy
is a font of forgetfulness truth ah
lethia is the antidote
to lethe memory
in other words is deeply implicated
in the career of truth
so let's come back to the question what
is liberal
about a liberal arts education
as professor cops reminded us
this afternoon in his excellent talk the
word liberal comes from the latin word
liber which means free
the original reason that a liberal arts
education was so prized
was because it promised to free students
from the rust
of prejudice and presentism
the belief that the present moment is
the summit of wisdom
and enlightenment and that accordingly
the past is nothing more than a
graveyard of discredited
and mostly malignant ideas
is liberal education still
liberal in that sense
i'd wager that everyone in this room
knows george santayana's observation
that he who is ignorant of the past
is destined to repeat it
that is one reason we put such stock by
education we believe
that when successful education can help
rescue us
from making the same mistakes that
earlier generations had made
when i ponder the recent itinerary of
education in this country
and not just college education but the
whole shebang
i often think of that old advertisement
for a brand of cigarettes
designed to appeal especially to women
you've come a long way baby
how right they were but a distance
a distance traveled is not necessarily
a progress logged it was not so long ago
that
cardinal newman's enumeration of the
goals of a liberal education
could have been taken as a motto by the
american
academic establishment newman said that
the
chief objects of a university education
were and i quote
a cultivated intellect a delicate
taste a candid equitable dispassionate
mind
a noble and courteous bearing
in the conduct of life
that educational ambition was quite
normal in the eighteen fifties
but today
or consider the observation made by the
philosopher john
searle that quote the idea that the
curriculum should be converted to any
partisan purposes is a perversion
of the ideal of a university
the attempt to convert the curriculum
into an instrument of
social transformation he said
whether it be leftist rightist centrist
or whatever
is the very opposite of higher education
until the day before yesterday searle's
warning was regarded
as common sense now
it is uncommon in highly provocative
wisdom
how easy it is to forget the journey
that led us into this situation
now i'm not suggesting that in the past
our educational institutions always
lived up perfectly to the ideal that
newman
enunciated or that they always avoided
the perversion
against which professor cyril warned but
they aspired to
indeed until at least the middle 1960s
there was robust agreement about the
intellectual and moral goals of a
liberal arts education
even if those goals seemed difficult to
achieve
there was for example a shared
commitment to the ideal of
disinterested scholarship devoted to the
preservation and transmission of
knowledge
which meant the preservation and
transmission
of a civilization pursued in a community
free from ideological intimidation
if we inevitably fell short of the ideal
the ideal
nevertheless continued to command
respect and to exert
a guiding influence
the truth is that despite widespread
concern
about the fate of higher education and
despite many
and various efforts to call attention
and remedy it
the reality is in many ways far
greater today than it was in the 1970s
and 1980s when exotic phenomena
such as afrocenter postcolonial studies
queer theory critical legal studies and
the attack on science by
anti-humanistic humanists was just
beginning to gather steam
and despite the rise of alternative
voices here and there
and since i'm at hillsdale let me stress
the word
here those dominating the discussion at
most institutions
are committed to discrediting the
traditional humanistic ideals of
liberal education by injecting politics
into the heart
of the educational enterprise
consider the phenomenon the phenomena of
multiculturalism
and political correctness and i always
think of putting scare quotes around the
word
multiculturalism because really it is a
form of
monocultural animus directed against the
dominant culture
the multiculturalists claim to be
fostering a
progressive cultural cosmopolitanism
distinguished by superior sensitivity to
the downtrodden
and dispossessed in fact
they encourage an orgy of
self-flagellating liberal guilt
as impotent as it is insatiable
hence the woke sensitivity of the
multiculturalist
is an index not of moral refinement but
of moral
vacuousness multiculturalism
is a paralyzing intoxicant its thrill
centers around the emotion of superior
virtue
its hangover subsists on a diet of
ignorance
and blighted good intentions
the crucial thing to understand about
multiculturalism
is that notwithstanding its
emancipationist rhetoric
it is not about recognizing general
cultural diversity
or encouraging pluralism it is about
undermining the priority of western
liberal values in our
educational system and indeed in our
society
at large in essence as the political
scientist samuel huntington pointed out
multiculturalism is quote anti-european
civilization
it is basically said huntington an
anti-western ideology
now the most ironical aspect of this
whole spectacle
is that what appears to its adherence as
bravely anti-western
is in fact a part of the west's
long tradition of self-scrutiny
indeed criticism of the west has been a
prominent
ingredient in the west's
self-understanding
at least since socrates invited his
fellow athenians
to debate with him about the nature of
the good life
no civilization in history has been as
consistently
self-critical as the west in attacking
western civilization
the multiculturalist is also attacking
the liberating spirit
of self-scrutiny replacing it with
fashionable
dogmas of indoctrination
anti-americanism occupies such a
prominent
place on the agenda of the culture wars
precisely because the traditional values
of american identity
articulated by the founders and grounded
in a commitment to individual liberty
limited government and public virtue
are deeply at odds with the radical
de-civilizing tenets of the
multiculturalist enterprise
of political correctness a profound
ignorance of the milestones of american
or indeed of any other culture
is one predictable result the statistics
have become proverbial
huntington quotes one poll showing that
while 90 percent of ivy league
students could identify rosa parks only
25 percent could identify the author of
the words
government of the people by the people
for the people
another survey revealed that 40 percent
of seniors at 55 top
colleges could not say within half a
century
when the civil war was fought
the erosion of shared memory is such a
potent
tool of tyranny because it dissolves
those links with the past that give
substance to liberty
the founding father james wilson was
right when he observed that quote
law and liberty cannot rationally become
the object of our love unless they first
become the objects
of our knowledge we must know the past
in order to profit from its lessons
it almost goes without saying that the
tenured or
soon to be tenured radicals now
controlling nearly
all of the most prestigious humanities
departments in this country
reply that their critics have overstated
the case
really they say there is nothing amiss
nothing has happened that need concern
parents
trustees alumni government
or other private funding sources
on the issue of enforcing politically
correct behavior
on campus for example they will assure
you that the whole thing has been
overblown by
conservative journalists who do not
sufficiently admire multiculturalism
and cannot appreciate that the free
exchange of ideas
must sometimes be curtailed for the
higher virtue of protecting the feelings
of designated victim groups
and the curriculum they will say has not
been politicized it has been merely
democratized opened up
to reflect the differing needs and
standards of groups
and ideas hitherto insufficiently
represented in the academy
the aim of such objections is not to
enlighten
or persuade but to intimidate and to
preempt criticism
the truth is that what we are facing
today is nothing less
than the destruction of the fundamental
premises that underlie our conception
both of a liberal education
and of a liberal democratic polity
respect for rationality and the rights
of the individual
a commitment to the ideals of
disinterested criticism and colorblind
justice advancement according to merit
not according to sex race or ethnic
origin these quintessentially western
ideas
are bedrocks of our political as well as
our
educational system and they are
precisely the ideas
that are now under attack by progressive
academics
intoxicated by the coercive
possibilities
generated by their self-infatuating
embrace
of political correctness
political correctness also fosters an
atmosphere of
intimidation and encourages a
slavish moral and intellectual
conformity
attacking the very basis for the free
exchange of ideas
even worse it encourages a kind of
intellectual
sentimentality that makes it difficult
to acknowledge
certain unpalatable realities the
reality
for example that not all cultures or
indeed all
individuals are equal in terms of
potential or
accomplishment it insinuates that
dreadful
lie in the soul that socrates warned
about in the republic
politics the late journalist andrew
breitbart once observed
is downstream from culture
in the united states a primary engine of
culture
is the educational establishment since
the late 1960s
it has been anything but an ivory tower
a quiet semi-cloistered readout
deliberately subsisting at one remove
from partisan passions on the contrary
the educational establishment in this
country and this goes for primary and
secondary education as well as for
colleges
has incorporated those partisan passions
as part of its raison dutch
the chief question is this
should our institutions of higher
education be devoted primarily to
education of citizens
or should they be laboratories for the
social
for social and political experimentation
traditionally a liberal arts education
involved both
character formation and learning
the goal was to produce men and women
who
as alum bloom memorably put it had
reflected
thoughtfully on the question what is man
in relation to his highest aspirations
as opposed to his low and common needs
in recent decades however colleges and
universities
have more and more been home to what the
literary critic lionel trillian called
the adversary culture of intellectuals
the goal is rejection and repudiation
not reflection now the key issue i
hasten to add
is not partisan politics per se
but rather subordinating the
subordinating of intellectual life
to non-intellectual that is to say
political imperatives
indeed it is this failure a failure
to check the colonization of
intellectual life by
politics that stands behind and
fuels the degradation of liberal
education
the issue is less the presence of bad
politics
than the absence of non-politics in the
intellectual life
of the university
now what has happened to the educational
establishment
cannot be understood from its cultural
context
that long march through the institutions
that the italian marxist antonio
gramsci recommended and whose american
lineaments i chronicled in my book
the long march how the cultural
revolution of the 1960s changed
america the age of aquarius i wrote in
that book's introduction
did not end when the last electric
guitar was unplugged at woodstock
it lives on in our values and our habits
and our tastes pleasures and aspirations
it lives on especially in our emotional
and cultural institutions and in the
degraded pop culture that permeates our
lives
like a corrosive fog
we have been seeing the results of this
dissemination everywhere
in the media in the corporate board
rooms
where resolutions deploring systemic
racism are touted by
quivering virtue signaling bureaucrats
throughout the federal government where
workshops on critical race theory
category catechize government workers
about the evils of
whiteness and the glories of trans
culture
and just this past summer on our city
streets
where antifa and the trained marxists
of black lives matter rampaged
under the protection of the first
amendment while endeavoring to destroy
the political culture
that underwrites such protections
it is a great irony that the free speech
movement
which began in 1964 in the tumult of
berkeley
has over the years mutated into
something
close to the opposite a kind of
anti-free speech
movement that approaches opinions with
which it disagrees
by attempting to cancel them
it is not at all uncommon on our
nation's campuses to find academics
decrying academic freedom in the name of
a putatively
higher virtue at many institutions
liberal education has mutated into
intolerant indoctrination
a similar process of mutation or
reversal
has been at work throughout the
so-called liberal institutions of
western society
in the corporate boardrooms no less than
in the media
government bureaucracies and such
cultural institutions as museums
indeed the metastasis of ill liberal
liberalism beyond the protected pearl
use of
academia is one of the signal cultural
deformations of our time
what it tokens is nothing less than the
potential eclipse
of that robust understanding of liberal
society
that has informed the self-understanding
of the anglo-sphere
at least from the time and time of
runnymede and the adoption of magna
carta
at its core stand the ideals of free
speech
religious liberty and equality before
the law
the repudiation of such values and the
value of limited government
which is a political precondition for
the thriving of those ideals
has underwritten the redefinition of
liberalism
from the championship of freedom to
ill liberal politically correct
conformity
it's perhaps worth pausing to remind
ourselves
that free speech does not exist in
isolation
it is part of a constellation of
freedoms that include for example
freedom of conscience and the freedom
implicit in the idea
that all men are equal before the law
those freedoms are or were
bedrock principles in the modern secular
west but increasingly they are up for
grabs in a situation where
dissent from orthodoxy is met not with
disagreement
but with efforts at suppression
scapegoating
and ostracism the entire army
armory of so-called cancel culture
it is worth noting too how many new
disciples
of intolerance begin by proclaiming
their allegiance
to freedom only to redefine it out of
existence
freedom of speech is one thing said one
such campaigner
but you usage of your freedom should not
be to offend others or advocate
hate speech or provoke people to
violence
not that little word but freedom of
speech is one thing but
what a common marker in this debate is
the phrase
hate speech we're supposed to say yes to
free speech
but deplore hate speech speech
as one partisan of this milk toast
version of free speech put it
that offends or insults in general
now of course the law has long had
statutes against speech that incites
violence
or that imperils public order
gratuitously crying
fire in a crowded theater for example
but the phrase hate speech is like that
other item
in the lexicon of les leftis
redress social justice
it is a weapon masquerading as a moral
imperative
the adjective is cognitively vacuous but
emotionally charged
it injects an intoxicating dose of moral
self-righteousness that inc that clouds
the head
even if it sets the heart a flutter
now the large issue here is one that has
bedeviled
liberal societies ever since there were
liberal societies
namely that in attempting to create the
maximally
tolerant society we also give scope
to those who would prefer to create the
maximally
intolerant society it's the old
leninist cradle in action demand
freedom toleration and diversity when
out of power
practice suppression control and the
elimination of opponents
when in power it's a curious phenomenon
liberalism implies openness to other
points of view
even it would seem to those points of
view
whose success would destroy liberalism
extending tolerance to those points of
view
is a prescription for suicide
but intolerance betrays the fundamental
premise
of liberalism namely openness
as robert frost once put it a liberal is
someone who refuses to take his own part
in an argument
the escape from this disease of
liberalism lies in understanding that
tolerance and openness must be limited
by
positive values if they are not to be
vacuous
american democracy for example affords
its citizens
great latitude but great latitude is not
synonymous
with the proposition that anything goes
alan bloom put it well the fact he wrote
in the closing of the american mind
that there have been different opinions
about good
and bad in different times and places
in no way proves that none is true
or superior to others
our society like every society is
founded on particular
positive values the rule of law for
example
respect for the individual religious
freedom
the separation of church and state
or think of that robust liberalism
expressed by sir
charles napier the british commander in
india
in the early 19th century told that
immolating widows on few the funeral
pyres of their husbands
was a cherished local custom napier said
very well we also have a custom when
when men burn a woman alive we tie a
rope around their necks and we hang them
build your funeral pyre beside it my
carpenters will build the gallows
you may follow your custom then we will
follow ours
the point is that the openness that
liberal society rightly
cherishes is not a vacuous openness to
all points of view
it is not value neutral it need not
indeed it cannot
say yes to all comers to the islam of
fascists
who after all has his point of view just
as much as the soccer mom
who has hers western democratic society
is rooted
in a particular vision of what aristotle
called the good for man
the question is the question is do we
as a society still have confidence
in the animating values of that vision
do we possess the requisite will
to defend them or was the french
philosopher jean francois
revel right when he said that democratic
civilization
is the first in history to blame itself
because another power is trying to
destroy it
the jury is still out on these questions
and how they are answered
will determine the future not only of
western universities
but also of that astonishing spiritual
political experiment that is western
democratic
liberalism that liberalism is embodied
in the virtues of disinterestedness and
impartiality
the unbiased discernment of truth
it is symbolized for example by the
statue of justice adorning our
courthouses blindfolded
and holding a scale to declare her
allegiance to law
not men it is implicit in martin
luther king jr's observation that what
matters is not the color
of your skin but the content of your
character
the entire premise of black lives matter
is antithetical to the aspirations of
equality
in king's hopeful sense indeed with its
angry
caudill that asserting all lives matter
is racist and therefore impermissible
the blm movement is an inversion of
king's message
just as it is an affront to the ideal of
impartiality
on which the rule of law depends
but the attack on that ideal long
predates
the blm movement it is woven deeply into
the culture of repudiation
that fueled the radicalism of the 1960s
and undermined the humanistic tradition
that once upon a time
our universities existed to foster and
hand down
the cultural critic christopher lash
diagnosed it with great clarity a
misplaced
compassion lash wrote in his
posthumously published book
the revolt of the elites degrades
both the victims who are reduced to
objects of pity
and there would be benefactors who find
it easier to pity
their fellow citizens than to hold them
up to impersonal standards
attainment of which would entitle them
to respect
lash and old-fashioned liberal
understood that embracing democracy
does not entail a debasement of
standards
equality rightly understood requires a
respect
for impartial cannons of achievement
this insight lay at the center of
matthew arnold's culture
and anarchy culture
as arnold regarded it does not try to
teach
down to the level of inferior classes
it seeks to do away with classes
to make the best that has been thought
and known in the world
current everywhere
hence it is arnold wrote that the men of
culture
are the true apostles of equality
the great men of culture are those who
have had a passion for diffusing
for making prevail for carrying from one
end of society to the other
the best knowledge the best ideas
of their time today of course
the contention that some ideas are
better than others let alone
that some deserve to be called the best
is rejected as
an elitist crime against diversity
the cult or the ideology of diversity
what we have baptized as identity
politics
which represents the systematic
rejection
of everything connected with
impartiality and objective
impersonal standards is the enabling
presupposition
of the destructive cauldron of racialist
obsession
in which our society is now marinating
the irony is that our current
intolerance
is the perverted progeny of the primary
liberal value of openness it used to be
to quote alan bloom one last time
that openness was the virtue that
permitted us to seek the good
by using reason it now means
accepting everything and denying reasons
power
the unrest unrestrained and thoughtless
thoughtless pursuit of openness he
concludes has rendered openness
meaningless if you doubt this you could
turn
in tune in to the evening news and
listen to fancy people
explain why destroying someone else's
property is not
violence while keeping one's own counsel
and refusing to join in the mob and
ritual orgies of denunciation and
self-abasement
is violence
a couple of concluding observations
in his book notes toward the definition
of culture
t.s eliot noted that quote culture is
the one thing
we cannot deliberately aim at it is the
product
of a variety of more or less harmonious
activities
each pursued for its own sake
for its own sake that is one
simple idea that is everywhere in peril
today
when we plant a garden it is bootless to
strive directly for
for camellias they are the natural
product of our care
nurture and time we can manage it still
when it comes to
agriculture when we turn our hands to
koltura anime to the cultivation of the
soul
we seem to be considerably less
successful
let me end by noting that the opposite
of conservatism
or conservative is not liberal
but ephemeral russell kirk once observed
that he was conservative because he was
liberal
that is committed to freedom kirk's
formulation
may sound paradoxical but it touches on
a great
truth to be conservative
that means wanting to conserve what is
worth preserving
from the ravages of time and ideology
evil and stupidity so that freedom
may thrive in some plump
eras the task is so easy we can almost
forget how necessary it is
at other times the enemies of
civilization
transform the task of preserving our
culture
into a battle for survival
and that i believe and i say it
regretfully
is where we are today thank you
i'm happy to uh entertain comments
questions and versions
of freedom in the 21st century following
this session on the second floor of
cyril
we now have some time for a q a please
make your way down the aisle if you have
a question
so i've noticed a lot of schools similar
to hillsdale have a very small
student body while the schools that
maybe advocate for some of these
degenerative educational practices have
a really high student body
and i was wondering if there's a way we
can prevent the masses from having such
poor education if
schools like this are very uh very few
and far between
can everyone hear me
oh okay great
i would say that hillsdale is unique not
just unusual
but unfortunately it's worse
than your question suggests because
many of the very worst petri dishes
incubating this disease are small
schools
all of the top all i believe all of the
you know so-called top liberal arts
uh fancy schools especially in the east
for some reason
they may have a student body of a couple
thousand or a few thousand they're small
they're expensive they have too much
money
but they are assiduous in
promulgating all of the worst
aspects of this cultural revolution
that i intimated they're just as bad as
the huge schools and in fact
worse because the large schools
while they may be intellectually less
distinguished
are in many cases given over to
other pursuits they're not really
concerned with liberal arts education
although they may
say so when they send out their
fundraising letters and so on
but they're really concerned about in
many cases not at all but in many cases
is a kind of vocational education which
is fine
there's nothing wrong with that but it's
they are not really
part of the uh of the effort to pass on
this
liberal tradition i was talking about so
i think it's
it's not just a matter of numbers it's
really a matter of
quality
thank you for coming mr kimball i think
i
started reading the new criteria
criterion my father would
ear market for me probably by the time i
was 14 or so and i don't know has
anybody ever
maybe it's the bow tie i think euberson
was almost a dunkin strike the chapel
architect
i don't know did anybody else notice
that actually he's my twin
makes sense i just want to ask um
you mentioned that uh for
it's not the idea that uh education
ought to be free from ideological bent
itself and or an ideological or
philosophical if you'll forgive the
equivocation
uh proposition when considered in the
context of the modern state
so i say the modern state in contrast to
the ancient or
medieval medieval regimes which just did
not have the power to be so
all-encompassing
in terms of state or government
involvement in education so for example
today hillsdale's independence from
government seems to imply
an ideological bent when ideally it
wouldn't
right
well every society
and indeed every common pursuit depends
upon
an affirmation of
certain values and
there is a sense in which that
affirmation is political
but when it comes to liberal education
the political affirmation
turns importantly on the idea
that none of us has a monopoly on the
truth and therefore
it is a good thing to foster
a community where people can follow
the argument according to their own best
lights
and talk about it with other people and
debate it
that is not a political activity
although it depends upon a previous
decision that being able to engage in
that kind of
free debate is a worthwhile thing to do
so when people say
well it's a
just as politicized as yale or williams
or something because
their decision to be free from
government intrusion
is a political act
and there's some truth to that but where
that falls down i think
is in failing to recognize
that by essentially
taking yourself out of
the influence of people who want to
rule the way in which you conduct
yourselves
[Music]
you have
not become
slaves to somebody else but are free
so it seems to me that it's um
you you often see people make this
rhetorical move
they'll say well you know isn't that
just as political as
uh being non-political and you saw this
for example
the phrase i alluded to it although i
don't think i quoted it
this summer uh people would say silence
is violence
well no it isn't violence is violence
silence is silence and uh
this the kind of metabolism of this
uh phenomenon that you're talking about
is something that it's
it's very important to be alert to
because it's used not in good faith but
it's used as a sort of bludgeon
to try to make it impossible to pursue
a genuinely liberal arts education and
beyond that
to pursue a genuinely liberal
society where people live together
because they affirm
certain basic values about the nature of
their society
but are otherwise free to pursue their
lives
and to disagree and
engage in public spirited debate
we are in a situation now not just in
our educational
lives but in the life of this country
where
uh dissent is regarded
as a kind of criminal act and it's
uh instead of it's it's sort of like
heresy
and down that path is a very
very dangerous end
uh i think we still have time to
step back from the abyss but we are
close to the abyss
they do have to be balanced with
preserving a national culture necessary
to sustain a country
so there's a tension there how much
nuance would you introduce into that
conversation
if if i understood your question it's uh
multiculturalism is not necessarily bad
because it
it it provides diversity and that sort
of yeah well the problem is that what
goes under the name
of multiculturalism is
not there's no multi about it it really
is
a kind of as i said i think of sort of a
monocultural
um passion
so if you actually look
at what is being taught
as multicultural you'll find that really
it's just a series of cliches the people
who are probably getting it don't know
for example
other languages if you really wanted to
be multicultural you would
you would learn the languages of these
other cultures that you were
you know pretending to talk about but no
it's really it's
it's a kind of fancy
polysyllabic form of
uh monocultural
passion at least
that's how i have experienced it
whenever i've looked into
into the way in which it's actually
promulgated on campuses
it's it's taught not as a way
of learning about other cultures
but as a way of undermining
western culture it's all cultural all
cultures are equal
except they're all superior to the west
it's a kind of
version of what orwell talked about
in animal farm all cultures are
all animals are equally so but some are
more equal than others
question to the speaker's left hi uh
thank you for being here mr kimball
um this kind of speaks to the question
that was just asked but
um in your speech you discussed how
multiculturalism and
pluralism have corrosive effects on our
education and our society at large
but um i was wondering is there a seed
of
good or something valuable in these
ideas
and in other words um what does the
non-western world have to teach us
well the non-western world might have a
lot to teach us but
it's been my experience first of all
that
what goes under the banner of
multiculturalism actually
doesn't really learn very much about the
non-western world
and secondly it seems to me that
as americans we want to be able to
affirm who we are first
before pretending to uh
a criticize our society and be
adopt as if we are sort of a vacationing
other cultures
i think if you actually look at what is
taught
in uh colleges under the banner of
multiculturalism you'll find that
most often it's composed very largely
of anti-western animus rather than
genuine intellectual curiosity about
other cultures
that said i think it's important to
understand
that i think i mentioned this just in
passing
that all cultures really are not equal
and you know uh saul bella got into a
lot of trouble
when he asked where's the toll story of
the zulus
people didn't like that but that is not
an illegitimate question
it seems to me now there might be there
might be a great
uh a novelist of the zulus i don't know
uh but it's important to be able to tell
the truth about things and to call
things by their real
names and i think that there's a great
sentimentality
among some americans about the virtues
of other cultures
that the more you look at them the less
justified that
seems a a uh a novelist who is very
brilliant i think uh in brutal about
exposing that was vs nypal
who himself was from trinidad i think
and really understood a lot about
other cultures but he also understood
the
toxic effects of sentimentalizing those
cultures especially for
for uh people from the west
hello thank you for coming up tonight um
this kind of relates to an earlier
question so i apologize for repeating
anything here
but one thing you mentioned was how the
uh
apolitical has become politicized um
and the intellectual kind of political
is entering into it
and i was just wondering if you could
speak a little more uh what do we do
about this
so for example a book like huckleberry
finn
which could be put in a great books
curriculum
uh it's now become a political statement
just to put it in the curriculum in a
way that it wasn't
not too long ago um so is there a way we
have to
de-politicize the apolitical or are
is it too late for that is um what can
we do to recover
just reading huck finn because it's a
great book um
and for no other political aim other
than that
yeah that i think that's a very good
question
what we can do is
say quite frankly to the people who say
we're offended
by huckleberry finn
or othello
or teaching chaucer
who's after all the dead white guy some
famous college has just taken chaucer
out of its
curriculum is to say no
we are we are going to uh the fact that
you're offended
uh offends me and so we're not going to
uh we're not going to um submit
to this politically correct
effort and intimidation instead
we are going to look to the past
for the criterion of
literary artistic cultural achievement
why well david hume
said so what what is a work of genius
and he said it's
durable appreciation those works that
have been appreciated
for a long time and of course now
that phenomenon changes you know
things go in and out of uh out of uh
fashion it was a in the
uh middle of the 19th century
people like shelly and byron thought
tasso was terrific
very few people read tasso anymore
there was a a time when walter scott was
thought to be you know top dog when it
came to novelists i think scott has not
really read that much anymore
but the point is these matters of taste
i think should be determined by
impartial standards by i mean taste you
know taste is an interesting
thing isn't it
[Music]
it's pretty clear emmanuel kant pointed
this out in his
critique of judgment there's different
kinds of taste
you might like your steak well done i
might like mine where that's
a kind of aesthetic judgment aesthetic
meaning
having to do with sensation but we we
understand that
that the sort of taste that's involved
in
literary judgment is something different
and what is different about that well
kant has his little schema
actually it's not so little but he has a
he has a way of explaining that
but it's to basically appeal
to a larger community
and he says that that um
that aesthetic judgment in that sense
has an ennobling and enlarging
effect well that that's you know
obviously a
a hint of a of a long discussion
why is it we you might ask why do we
think
that works of art are important clearly
we do
because we spend millions and millions
and millions of dollars building museums
and acquiring works of art why do we
think education is important
again clearly we do need to i mean there
are 4 500 institutions of education
higher education in this country
so we think that there's something
important about it even if
to some very large extent we've sort of
lost sight of that
but it seems to me that the most
important loss
is exactly what you're talking about
being able to judge
these works on their own terms
that's why i mentioned at the uh
toward the end that you you do something
for its own sake it's not for some
ulterior utilitarian motive it's because
it's a good work of art and
um again there's always going to be
discussion
disagreement about that but that's what
makes life interesting
that kind of disagreement to have
someone say no you can't read this
because it has words i don't approve of
in it
that's not on i would say
thank you mr kimball we have time for
one final question
hello thank you for um your comments
tonight uh my question
is related to the religious language you
used
specifically with some of the opponents
of liberal education
and with that level of commitment to
their ideas
and devaluation of reason in dialogue
what do you
see or what do you prescribe as a means
to combat that for people
that would adhere to reason as being the
superior means
to go about these issues
are your opposing reason to religion or
uh no so when you were when you were
speaking of some of
uh the contemporary um ideas you
you used language like baptized and
things like that
and and i think rightly there is like a
religious element of this
um but but in that they've devalued
reason
um in a way that makes it hard for
people that are liberals
in in another sense to use reason to
combat it so what would you prescribe
for me a means to combat something that
is religious in nature and antithetical
to using reason
okay so i mean sort of the the the cult
kind of uh yeah well i think first of
all
the the first step is recognizing
what something is and calling it by its
real name as i just said to the last
chap um you know there's a book by
a man named norman cohn
called the pursuit of the millennium and
it's all about
these medieval uh
you know movements that like the
the the the the the brotherhood of the
free spirit
people who felt that they had somehow
achieved a higher level
of virtue than the other people in their
society and this
this enabled them to do all kinds of
things like they were not
bound anymore by the normal morality of
the people who were not enlightened
they could do whatever they want because
they they occupied a higher plane
of enlightenment and a direct connection
so they thought with
with the godhead uh you know they might
say that all material
the whole material world is evil uh
except
since i understand that i'm no longer
bound by the
the normal codes of morality if that
sounds a lot like what happened
in the 1960s you're quite right it's
also what happened by the way
in the french revolution why was it why
was it that
robes pierre the the
disciple of jean-jacques rousseau why
was it that the word
virtue was always on his lips he took
that word
and that concept from rousseau and
the idea being that he wanted to create
a virtuous society
society was not virtuous robespierre
thought so we have to get rid of certain
p the people who are unvirtuous
in my sense said rose pierre they have
to be gotten rid of
so the index of uh
virtue for the french revolution was the
rapidity with which the guillotine got
rid of those who are not virtuous
it's a it's it's a poisonous
a poisonous idea and um
again you don't have to look very far in
our society
to see that kind of sentiment
at work uh if you
pay attention to the rhetoric of uh
black lives matter for example or antifa
or certain
members of that large building in
washington that's now surrounded by a
12-foot fence and razor wire
you you hear scary echoes of that kind
of
of thing they're virtuous and you're not
and they believe that with a religious
fervor
which does not invite conversation or
disagreement
but like any heresy it invites
condemnation and being stamped out
[Music]
thanks